which brings us to some of the really
cool new features that we put in for the
ps4 this time around so you know we
always think that playing with your
friends is the best way to experience
diablo 3 and it's the most fun way to
experience the habló 3 but you know
sometimes your schedules don't always
line up and you can't always get
together online at the same time or in
the same house at the same time so we've
looked at putting in some asynchronous
multiplayer features so probably the
most straightforward of these is mail so
we've added a mail system with a mailbox
where you can send items to your friends
you want to share them with them and
building off of that we've also
incorporated something we're calling
player gifts so anytime that a legendary
item drops in the world for you there's
a chance that a gift will spawn for one
of the friends on your friends list so I
could be playing and it could drive I
would say a gift for a Randi and if I
interact with that gift it'll go
directly then to your mailbox and the
next time that you log on and you go to
your mailbox and you open that gift it
will roll for the character who opens it
which gives it the best chance of being
a high-value item for that character
that you're playing at that time and
then it's sort of then further building
on that we have a whole new system
called the Nemesis system which I'm
gonna let Matthew jump in and talk about
here yeah we in the off chance that you
died in this game not that that would
ever happen of course to you the monster
that kills you has a chance to level up
he will turn into a different creature
he will gain new powers and he's gonna
open up a portal and he's gonna jump
into that portal and it disappeared from
your game and then somebody will if you
and I are friends and I'm playing I log
into the game a few days later I start
playing all of a sudden some ominous
music starts to play and weird signs
begin appearing and also the monster
jumps into my game and it's named after
you and it lets me know that it's your
killer it attacks me it's hunting me
down if I defeat it I'm gonna get loot
and some gifts are gonna drop for you
that I'm going to be able to sit back if
it kills me it will become even more
powerful jump into my friends list and
find one of my friend to play I'll go
through and hunt
so you know it's a way for us to set
kind of make it feel like we're not
playing at the same time but we're all
adventuring in the world of sanctuary
together really another new feature of
the ps4 version for Diablo 3 is what
we're calling a Prentiss mode so to help
you kind of keep playing with your
friends even if your schedules get you
off you know sometimes you'll be playing
together you'll start new characters and
then you know maybe something comes up
for someone else and you keep playing
and they don't pretty soon you bow
leveled them and then it's pretty hard
to get back together and keep playing so
then you feel like oh should I make a
new characters so with the princess mode
what we do is if you have a lower level
character and a higher level player
playing at the same time we temporarily
boost the lower level player for the
duration of that play session so I'll do
more damage so I'll that would be a
little bit tougher so they can survive
they can go toe-to-toe with you they can
contribute meaningfully to fights so you
can keep playing together and of course
loot the drops will still be appropriate
for the levels of the people that are
playing so you're not going to be either
saddle of loot that's too low or too
high for you and the experience levels
are the experiences that your game will
be appropriate to the levels of the
characters that are playing the lower
level player will get a little bit of an
experience boost on top of of the base
experience that's appropriate to them so
you can sort of help your care your
player your friends catch up as they're
playing with you it's slightly boosted
for the Lord lifted in two ways first
there's there's a general bonus because
you're playing with a friend so two
players get a little bit more experience
to begin with
and then on top of that we add a little
bit more once again for the lower level
player what we've done in the ps4
version is that we've made it so that
when loot drops on the ground it's it's
marketed as either player 1 player 2
player 3
no matter who picks it up it's gonna go
to the the inventory of the correct
person so you're no longer gonna have to
stop your game and go into your
inventory and say oh this dexterity item
that should go to the demon hunter since
we already knew in the background that
dexterity items should go to the demon
that's why we dropped it we're just
gonna send it straight to the demon
hunter so you know all the all the
changes that are being made by the PC
team the few updates that they are doing
right now we are inheriting so the game
is going to be very finely tuned we have
updated some of the action combat
elements so for instance the destruction
bonuses when you destroy five or more
items now you piece of furniture barrels
now you actually get a speed boost on
console
what you don't PC the massacre which is
you know kill your kill streak we
display that much more prominently we
give you much bigger experience booze we
have also the killing enemies with traps
we're experimenting giving it a resource
boost so we're trying to leverage all
the systems that already exist in a new
way to make it feel even more fun on
console that more kinetic vibe yeah you
think you know once you added the
controller or the direct control of the
character it just kind of naturally gave
the game more of an arcade II kind of
feel and so by kind of amping up these
existing massacre destruction trap
systems to what we're calling action
combat it just it just emphasizes kind
of that Arkady field it's encouraging
you to keep your kill count going chain
kills chain destruction of objects we're
also tying in Nephilim glory to the
massacre system so each time that you
reach a new level of massacres or like
10 20 30 monsters killed there's a
chance that you'll drop a Nephilim glory
globe so it gives you a little bit more
control over getting those power-ups for
your character
and of course since it has all of Reaper
souls and all of the original game very
good acts one through five Wow
I got lucky you you got both of those
yeah I don't it has X 1 through 5 it has
a new crusader class so all six classes
it has adventure mode therefore if the
Bounty's mystic artisans all that
content is there so there's a there is a
lot for you to play